on va bien sûr accueillir celles voilà
dans tout le monde a parlé cette semaine
c'est la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité hommes-femmes c'est marlène
schiappa
merci d'être là alors je vous ai mis un
tabouret un paper board est votre avis
voilà mes biens merci d'être là en tout
cas c'est courageux de votre part de
devenir voulez vous asseoir peut-être ça
va jusqu ici très bien pas très bien
alors est ce que voulaient nous dire un
petit mot avant que des ivoiriens
d'abord merci d'abord bonsoir bonsoir et
merci de m'accueillir merci à vous déjà
s'il parce que vous n'étiez pas obligé
dire oui ma proposition
effectivement on a eu pas mal de
commentaires et de réactions un peu
épidermique et pavlovienne en ma
direction mais en la vôtre aussi
et donc merci parce que vous avez aussi
pris un risque en ouvrant votre plateau
ce soir je mangeais l'habitude ce soir
c'est vraiment je m'excuse j'ai pas
beaucoup de voix mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vous est ce que ça veut
dire que justement ce soir je suis venu
pour assez peu parlé et finalement
plutôt vous écouter et l'idée c'est de
voir comment ensemble on peut faire un
atelier du grand débat parce que vous
savez que le président la république a
lancé le grand débat national pour dire
que maintenant tous ensemble on va se
retrousser les manches et chercher des
solutions
moi je viens montrer ce soir non pas que
le gouvernement a raison parce qu'on a
pas raison sur tout mais je viens
montrer que participer à ce grand débat
c'est possible ici on va faire un
atelier autour de cyril hanouna autour
de vous je voudrais aussi que les gens
qui nous regardent se disent moi aussi
je vais participer
je vais créer mon atelier sur le site
grand débat point fr et ensuite on va
tous ensemble contribuer tous ensemble
échanger et voir un peu comment on peut
être enthousiaste positif et trouver ce
qui nous réunit
et comment on peut faire des
propositions concrètes pour avancer
ensemble simple
merci alors moi je vous le dis on
voulait absolument que vous soyez là ce
soir c'est vrai aussi parce que vous
êtes vous êtes elle est un petit peu
notre notre message et on va dire voilà
parce que nous voilà nous on est on est
on est on se pose on s'y connaît où on
arrive et on a peut-être des idées mais
il faudrait nous éclairer sur des choses
voilà qu'on connaît pas moi c'est vrai
que je suis plutôt du côté des voies la
dalle et des deux de vous parce que moi
le vrai je comprends rien donc si vous
aviez parlé qu'à moi et pas forcément on
n'aurait pas pu faire avancer les choses
donc le fait qu'ils aient marlène
schiappa avec donc c'est vrai que ça
peut aller plus vite et vous vous allez
aussi nous éclairer